ومعنا من تل ابيب مراسل الجزيره الياس
كرام اهلا بك الياس الياس اي معلومات عن
هذه الاجتماعات اجتماع مجلس الحرب
والحكومه الامنيه
المصغره هو اجتماع المجلس الحربي وفي
اعقابه المجلس الوزاري المصغر للشؤون
السياسيه والامنيه في اسرائيل والمخول في
حسم القضايا الحساسه والمهمه في اسرائيل
ربما يعطينا فكره على ان المجلس الوزاري
المصغر ربما سيتخذ قرارات مصيريه او
سيناقش امرا مصيريا مهما هذه الليله يفترض
ان يتخذ فيه قرارات او يفترض ان يجري
التصويت عليه او على الاقل مناقشته على
نحو مستفيض ومن الواضح ان مساله تبادل
الاسرى او صفقه جديده لتبادل الاسرى هي
العنوان المركزي لهذا اللقاء وهذا
الاجتماع في مجلس الحرب الذي انعقد قبل
حوالي نصف ساعه وسيعقب بطبيعه الحال كما
قلنا اجتماع للمجلس الوزاري المصغر للشؤون
السياسيه والامنيه وهو ياتي ايضا على
خلفيه الانباء التي تحدثت عن اجتماع مرتقب
ايضا للوسطاء بحضور رئيس الشباك
الاسرائيلي ورئيس المساد ورئيس السي اي اي
الامريكي قريبا في احدى الدول الاوروبيه
وهذا ربما يكون اجتماع في غايه الاهميه
وربما يحمل في طياته صفقه جديده او
مقترحات جديده فيما يتعلق بتنفيذ صفقه
لتبادل الاسرى حقيقه ليس واضحا بعد ما هي
معالم هذه الصفقه لكن ربما المجلس الحربي
سوف يناقش الخطوط الحمراء بالنسبه له او
تلك الشروط التي وضعتها ايضا المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ازاء الموافقه والقبول باي
صفقه لتبادل الاسرار في هذا الخضم
بالامكان الاشاره الى ان المقا المقاومه
الفلسطينيه اولا رفضت اجلاء القيادات
العليا لحركه حماس السياسيه والعسكريه كما
كانت طلبت اسرائيل في بعض مقترحاتها
واشترطت ايضا في اطار اتمام اي صفقه
لتبادل الاسرى وقف الحرب وانسحاب اسرائيل
الكامل من قطاع غزه بالنسبه للشرط
الاخيرين يبدو ان هنالك خلاف كبير في داخل
مجلس الحربي وكذلك في المجلس الوزاري
المصغر وكذلك ايضا في الهيئه العامه للحك
الحومه الاسرائيليه بمعنى ان الجانب
الاسرائيلي يرفض جمله وتفصيلا التعهد بوقف
الحرب كليا ويرفض ايضا الانسحاب الكلي من
قطاع غزه اذا ربما تسالين ان هذا ربما
يقود الى فشل المفاوضات ليس بالضروره لان
هنالك ربما تكون مقترحات خلاقه يقدمها
الوسطاء
والواضح بان اي صفقه مستقبليه لن تتم دفعه
واحده بسبب هذه المشاكل وهذ هذه الخطوط
الحمراء انما ربما تتم من خلال مراحل
معينه اي موافقه اسرائيل من ناحيه على وقف
طويل لاطلاق النار ربما لشهر او شهرين ليس
معروفا بعد ما ما الذي يتتم الموافقه
عليه نشير فقط الى ما نراه على الشاشه من
هذه الصور لزياره هيرت ليفي رئيس اركان
الجيش الاسرائيلي وهو يجري تقييما امنيا
طبعا يزور القوات الاسرائيليه ويجري
تقييما امنيا بخان يونس بحضور قائد لواء
الجنوب وايضا قائد الفرقه
ال8 تفضل
الياس بالفعل هيرتس هاليفي وهذه ليست
الجوله التفقديه الاولى التي يقوم بها الى
خانيونس وهو قام بهذه الجوله اليوم بعد ان
كان اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي في الايام
الماضيه عن استكمال تطويق ومحاصر مدينه
خان يونس هاليفي اجتمع مع قائد اللواء
الجنوبي وقائد الفرقه 98 التي اوكلت اليها
مهمه القتال في منطقه خانيونس اي هيرتس
هاليفي استمع الى تقييييم امني حول ما
يسمونه في الجيش الاسرائيلي المنجزات
والانجازات على ارض الواقع في خان يونس
وتحدث بهذا السياق عن الجهود التي تقوم
بها القوات الاسرائيليه تحديدا في صفوف
قوات الاحتياط الاسرائيلي في القتال في
مناطق كثيفه ومقتضى وماهو وصعبه للغايه من
حيث القتال وجها الى وجه ومن حيث ما سماه
الافخاخ وال التصدي من جانب ايضا المقاومه
الفلسطينيه لهذه القوات الاسرائيليه وهالي
في في هذا السياق اشاد بعمل القوات
الاسرائيليه التي قال بانها حققت انجازات
كبيره على الارض في خضم هذه المعركه ومن
الواضح بان اسرائيل من خلال هذه العمليه
المتواصله في مدينه خان يونس تسعى الى
تعزيز الخناق او تكثيف الخناق على القياده
العليا لحركه حماس والمقاومه الفلسطينيه
التي تعتقد انها موجوده في منطقه خانيونس
وتحديدا في الانفاق الهجوميه اسفل المدينه
وهي تحاول ان تشكل من خلال العمليه
العسكريه ضغطا على القياده السياسيه
والعسكريه لكي تستخدمها ربما رافعه ايضا
في صفقه تبادل الاسرار شكرا جزيلا لك
الياس كرام كنت معنا من تل ابيب y